Ryan Leaf here on the Rich Eisen show
not a.m. 3 hours before you called the
Sun but you will be calling the Sun Belt
championship on ESPN between Louisiana
and a four-letter word for me
Appalachian State
good to see you Ryan Leaf how are you -
you got it so again
hot tea lemon and honey is the way
you're gonna get to that Sun Belt
champion chef 15th game speaking in
Chicago tomorrow morning heading to the
airport after this so I appreciate that
help you got it yeah so how do you think
it's gon gonna shake out I think the
committee told us on Tuesday night I
think they said by putting Utah at
number 5 if LSU does what they're
supposed to do and beats Georgia
I think Utah's is gonna win the pac-12
championship and get in you do think so
yep I think they told us they have not
they don't have a top 25 win mm-hmm
and Oklahoma has a top 7 win and they
still believe they're a better football
team
okay so Oklahoma would beat Baylor win
the big 12 championship but Utah goes as
the fourth seed if if Georgia beats LSU
you don't think LSU goes LSU beats
Georgia obviously if Georgia beat LSU
everybody's out like LSU and Georgia
will go with Clemson in Ohio State so
we'll be two SEC teams uh-huh now is
that part of you is that a pac-12 buys
for you that might be might be a little
bit just because I've seen him more than
anybody I mean you watched Paul Finebaum
yesterday just just you know blab all
about Utah and their ability not to get
to the game because I just don't think
he's watched him if you've watched Utah
you can tell they're they're one of the
best four teams and I think if they end
up playing LSU and round one that means
LSU has to leapfrog Ohio State if they
win I think that gives them the best
chance to get to the national
championship Utah can actually take on
LSU I do believe that defense is special
listen to you promise table for the Utah
Utes okay so you really think that the
Utah Utes win the pac-12 championship oh
so let's start let's start step one what
why do you think Utah beats Oregon on
this game what they've shown us all year
long defense offensive efficiency
Tyler Hartley has been the best
in the pac-12 and what he does at the
quarterback position and I mean they've
dominated they've been 21 21 28 and a
half point favorites the last three
weeks right and covered they're
destroying people they just don't want
to be people they want to put them under
the ground and that's what they've done
and I think they'll do it too or again
by double digits okay and then so Utah
gets in
if by dint of glory I don't even know
how that would happen over over Oklahoma
and I know about you know schedule and I
know about what you just mentioned about
how they're finishing strong it's also
with the ultimate of respect I here we
go with all due respect I actually just
went there right there did to the it's a
beautiful state Utah a lot of great
people there I'm heading there Sunday I
understand but but when it all comes
down to it I mean on the last Saturday
of this year when everybody's getting
around I mean are you are you gonna tune
into Utah versus LSU Utah versus Ohio
State you're gonna tune into Oklahoma
instead you're gonna Jalen hurts a
player that you've heard of and a team
that you've actually seen play on the
national stage with a head coach that's
rumored to be the apple of so many NFL
eyes and front office's you're still
gonna tune in it's the national
semifinal you're gonna tune in who
regardless of who it is and Utah's gonna
give whoever a better shot and run it
their money than the Oklahoma team well
I think Clemson no house they are the
best two teams in the country don't get
me wrong you do I do and I think Clemson
does something unprecedented and wins 15
again and goes 30 you know over the last
two years with two national
championships but I think Utah's gonna
be the number 14 Ryan Leaf here in the
Rich Eisen show why are you down on LSU
I mean you're saying that you die I'm
not saying that you don't think they're
special I'm saying that you're saying
Utah could beat them you're also saying
Clemson and Ohio State are the best two
teams why why don't you put LSU in that
category I do I mean I think they're one
of the top four teams I just think that
if anybody if Utah has a chance to beat
anybody in the semi-final it's gonna be
LSU just because their defense is so
good and if they can shut down Joe
burrow in that offense they have a shot
I don't think anybody can stop Ohio
State and Clemson and it would be a
shame if they played in the semi-final
I'd rather see the
the national champion well I mean if the
college football playoff committee is an
agreement with you they'll separate them
no they'll set a path up for for these
teams to face so I sat in that room and
I've watched how it played out in the
mock committee and it's just it's odd
they put these pools of six teams and
you know they're not thinking about that
stuff or at least they say they're not
thinking about stuff but I agree with
you there's something that plays into
all of this explain what you just you
just said for people in my not-so you
are now a mock committee so you were
invited to go down to the spot where the
committee takes place right and then go
through the process and mock it what the
actual committee goes through yes so I
got to go through the whole process and
ultimately there's 13 individuals but it
can break down as small as seven a
majority rules in that room okay and if
seven people believe that LSU is the
number one team in the country they're
gonna be the number one team in it
doesn't matter what the other six says
right they get voted out it's not like
it's not like an actual jury where it's
got to be in a can filibuster you can't
Lobby I mean you can Lobby but you have
to have backers there's almost like
Congress just without a filibuster oh
man
so okay Ryan leave here on the Rich
Eisen show now
Utah's only losses to USC and just
yesterday a lot of I don't know how to
put it there was a lot of eyebrows hue
and cry I'm still waiting for the first
USC fan that I know and there's tons of
them here or like you know Mike bone
that was a really good move the new ad
just let's stick with clay Helton he's
the guy we just need to improve part of
the program I don't know what that meant
do you agree with the maneuver that the
new athletic director at USC made when
sticking with clay Helton
if he didn't have a plan in place a true
plan of who he was gonna hire mm then
yes because if he by getting rid of one
guy and paying all that money just to
bring somebody in that just to replace
him with not your guy that doesn't do
good for anybody I know the fan base is
up in arms over this furious furious I
mean look this guy's a good guy he's
anybody who knows him
likes him he's you know a genuinely
passionate individual I don't know again
of a single USC fences good move and as
a matter of fact they're saying we don't
trust the new athletic directors do what
I'm I'm not ready to buy that I think
it's a good move I think there's just
some consistency especially with all the
nuance that's been going on at that
university stabilizing something he
probably had his best coaching here of
his career this year there's been five
ten win seasons in the history of USC
football five play only has three of
them he's a good football coach now the
recruiting process that's a different
scenario
he's been bad in recruiting because
because of this because of the fact that
they don't know who's gonna be the head
coach and Mike bone gave a boost of
confidence to say hey he's our guy for a
year that's the thing I would need to
see like some kind of extension because
guess what next year at this time are we
gonna be in the same boat that's the
problem with all this you just start
over or you commit and I don't know what
they did in this process by just saying
alright he's here again next year
ya know that's that's essentially it yep
oh my word cuz let's be honest here I
mean USC not in the pac-12 championship
and they used to be in the conversation
with oh I mean Alabama and Clemson they
were that I mean that was a chance they
get a chance they open the season next
year first game of the year against
Alabama and where's that in Dallas it's
probably gonna be a neutral site yeah
yeah but the pac-12 has chance next year
Ohio State goes to Eugene to play Oregon
mmm Michigan goes to Washington and week
one well and you know what I will be
livid livid if they make that a 9:00
a.m. Pacific Time Pacific start time
because I don't think they will that
would be that would make me absolutely
livid because you wouldn't want to get
up that early to watch it no no no no no
no no it's it's it's it's you take an
East Coast team or an Eastern time zone
team and send them to anywhere west and
say you're gonna play football at 9:00
in the morning who the hell does that
you have to wait
the team up at like 3:00 4:00 in the
morning and go through your routine and
play at 9 a.m. and be done and then for
to be the first guinea pig team to do
that
Michigan didn't sign for that when they
agreed to play it was Washington you
know millions of months ago do that no
but that's what I mean you never say
McPike 12 needs to be more relevant the
fact that we again to bring this
conversation full circle with you Ryan
Leaf is that we're talking about many
people believe doesn't matter what Utah
does I mean you're talking facts about
how good their defenses and about
results and about schedule but it may
not matter because folks are not gonna
as much as you say folks are gonna tune
into Utah because they're playing in a
nationally televised semifinal it's
still not a team that people know of or
used to or can get behind nationally or
just surf in just because they want to
watch football and part of the reason is
pac-12 football is played in the middle
of the night okay and nobody really sees
it on the East Coast they're asleep
yep so better way to do that it's put it
on it noon Eastern Time for the whole
country to see but Michigan shouldn't be
the first oral Hostetter any Eastern
time zone team a guinea-pig week one and
in a spot like Washington in in that in
that environment
it's insane enough to try and win there
put them together and put them at the
12:30 game turn times no put them at
12:30 wait till you get to the pac-12
right and then do the the guinea-pig of
the 9 a.m. okay so um by the way USC
Alabama is in the Jones Mahal it is in
Dallas Texas next year to kick things
off so your prediction would be what by
Sunday we will hear what for the college
football playoff I think we're gonna see
uh I think LSU is gonna jump Ohio State
okay with a win against number for
Georgia or this the way I hope it plays
out yes
clemson has been my number one team all
year long but they're not gonna be
placed at number one because I don't
have the resume to show for it so I got
LSU at 1 oh how stated to Clemson at 3
you taught for Utah upsets LSU in the
national semifinal place Clemson for the
national team
peejoe Clemson's the two-time defending
national championship that's how ice
that's how I see it all but that's how
you see it how do you think it will play
out if you're not correct
I think Ohio State probably stays at 1
mm so they can get the national
championship they want or how state
dominates the Utah team and the first
semifinal Clemson dominates an LSU team
in the second semi-final Ohio State
Clemson play much closer game than
people expect but ultimately Clemson
ends up wins it
Ryan thanks for coming in man again hot
tea lemon honey get on that plane you
know don't talk unless you really just
have to and I look forward to hearing
you full throated and Hardy Saturday
noon Eastern Time on ESPN calling the
Sun Belt championship Appalachian
applica against Louisiana and
Appalachian State again that's a
four-letter word for me thanks for
coming in man you bet you got it that's
at Ryan D leaf on both Twitter and
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app